what happens tonight if you sat down and
said hey I think we're
done I love you you've been so great to
my kids last five years you're really
the dad that they
know and we met in a really vulnerable
moment for me and a vulnerable season
for me and I'm so grateful that you were
there for me but you don't love me you
don't want to be
married what do you say as adults we
call
this and we'll figure out the finances
and I'll figure out what to do and we'll
go from
there because you'll have a legal claim
to some of the house you have a legal
claim to some of the assets and all that
stuff y'all can be adults about it and
split it up because you're not even
married or you can go to court and this
whole thing is going to be a
nightmare what does he say if you say
that